GOOD MORNING NO INTEREST TIME
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A A STE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO THAT WE. WE HAVE
PEOPLE OUR WORK HERE TO
REPRESENT THEIR BILLS I'M SURE
LEVINE SO WILL.
WELL WE CAN'T VOTE YET UNTIL WE
GET A QUORUM BUT WILL WILL BEGIN
AS A SUB COMMITTEE FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU AS WELL AS SOME NUMBER
LACKEY FORUM FOR YOUR
PUNCTUALITY THIS MORNING.
I I'M PRESENTING AB EIGHT
SEVENTY IT SIDE SOMEWHAT RUDE
BILL LAST YEAR THAT TIED HIM OFF
THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO ZERO. I TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATION THE GOVERNOR.
I VETOED THAT BILL SAME AT THAT
ALREADY OCCURRED HOWEVER. I IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
STATE AUDITOR DID COME OUT WITH
A REPORT SAYING THAT.
AND.
IN FACT.
AT THE. BUT THE PRISONS WERE
CONTINUALLY.
.
I FAILING TO MAKE THESE
EVALUATIONS.
AND SO THIS LIE OR THIS BILL IS
IN FACT NECESSARY IN LAW.
AND WE'RE JUST GONNA DO OUR WORK
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE GOVERNOR.
IS EDUCATED ABOUT THAT
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND HOPEFULLY
WILL BE ABLE TO SEND THAT BACK.
SEVENTY SEVEN TO ZERO AGAIN.
OR WHATEVER NUMBER OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WE HAVE.
THANK YOU HELLO AYE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ AND I'M DEAD DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER. WE
REPRESENT TEN THOUSAND SOULS
WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE THEIR
SOCIAL WORK DEGREE.
FROM SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT SEVENTY IN CALIFORNIA
JAILS AND PRISONS HAVE BECOME
ARE DE FACTO MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES. THOSE WHO ARE
MENTALLY ILL ARE FAR MORE LIKELY
TO BE INCARCERATED THAN TO BE IN
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS IN FACT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY JAIL HAS
BEEN CALLED THE LARGEST MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER IN THE COUNTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY CONDITIONS IN
PRISON PROTECT TYPICALLY
EXACERBATE MENTAL ILLNESS AND
THE COURTS HAVE FOUND THAT
PRISONS HAVE FAILED TO DELIVER
NECESSARY CARE TO MENTALLY ILL
INMATES.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY WOULD GIVE
COURTS THE ABILITY CAN STICK
CONSIDER MENTAL ILLNESS IS A
FACTOR IN CRIMINAL SENTENCING
AND CONNECT THE INDIVIDUAL WITH
A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
NEED TO ONCE AGAIN BECOME A
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF THEIR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
PARTY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR PERCHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
AND CERTAINLY WERE LAST YEAR AS
AS WELL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THE.
CONCERNS.
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD.
ALSO LIKE TO REITERATE THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE HERE
ABOUT. THE NEED FOR THE SAME.
.
REVIEW HAPPENING AT THE COUNTY
JAIL SO IT THIS IS NOT JUST AN
ISSUE OF FOR THE.
STATE PRESENCE BY THAT THEY.
GELS AS WELL SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO.
WORK WITH THE ART THERE TO SEE
IF WE CAN MOVE MORE TOWARD
GETTING THESE EVALUATIONS.
UP FRONT AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED
THAT THERE WAS STRONG SUPPORT IS
THE BILL MOVED LAST YEAR THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND THING THAT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBER.
FEET DID YOU MAKE CLOSENESS
LIVING.
WELL THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND THAT NUMBER FOR.
FOR HEARING THIS BILL AGAIN AND
MONEY OF QUORUM I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
THANK YOU SALINAS SINCE WE STEPS
A QUORUM WILL WILL VOTE ON YOUR.
RIGHT.
WE'RE WAITING FOR. BOTH MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND.
INDIVIDUALS TO TESTIFY.
HOW?
OKAY WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM.
HE. BENT SECRETARY CALL ROLE.
JONES SAWYER.
ALL I HEAR LACKEY NEW YEAR.
CORREO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO.
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
SEE.
BOB WE HAVE.
FOR DE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR. OUR REGULAR ORDER
BUSINESS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
EIGHT SIX
TWO MAIENSCHEIN.
.
SHOWS RENOVATION FINANCING AND
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FIFTEEN
ELEVEN LOW. ON SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENT PROPERTY LOSS.
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
KALRA.
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
CORREO. CORREO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
KILEY QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
IT SENT CALENDARS ADOPTED.
SO I GUESS WHILE WE'RE WAITING.
I CAN I CAN DO.
WE FINISH ITEM NUMBER THREE.
AB EIGHT SEVENTEEN A LEVINE
PRISONERS AND MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT IF THE ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHT SEVEN
THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CORREO.
CORREO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURE PASSES.
OKAY.
I GUESS I CAN PRESENT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE ET BE TO A TO A
PASSED THE GAVEL.
WITH FLORIDA OVER TO MR LACKEY
.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS A. AB TWO A
TWO IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT
PROVIDES A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO
THE STATUTE WHICH MAKES IT A
FELONY TO A ADVISE OR ENCOURAGE
A SUICIDE. AND TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT WHICH
ALLOWED A TERMINALLY ILL ADULT
WITH THE CAPACITY.
TO MAKE MEDICAL DECISIONS TO
REQUEST AN AIDE AND DYING
MEDICATION IF CERTAIN CONDITIONS
ARE MET.
THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT
INSULATES THE PRESCRIBING
PHYSICIAN AND A PERSON WHO IS
PRESIDENT TO ASSIST TO QUALIFY
PATIENT AND PREPARING TO DRUG
FOR CRIMINAL FROM FROM
CRIMINALLY. CRIMINAL LIABILITY
DEBT FOR ACTIONS WHICH ARE
AUTHORIZED UNDER THE ACT HOWEVER
WHEN THE END OF LIFE OPTION WAS
ENACTED THE PENAL CODE PROVISION
WHICH MAKES IT A CRIME TO EIGHT.
A SUICIDE WAS NOT UPDATED. TO
REFLECT THAT CHANGE.
THIS BILL MAKES THE NECESSARY
CHANGES AS SPECIFIES THAT
ACTIONS WHICH ARE AUTHORIZED
UNDER THE END OF LIFE OPTION ACT
CANNOT BE PROSECUTED UNDER THE
CRIMINAL STATUTE. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
IN A.
AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I WANT OPPOSITION.
MOVE TO HELP.
THEY'RE GONNA MOTION.
JERRY AND MOTION A SECOND YOU
HAVE A QUESTION COMMENT.
READY FOR YOUR CLOSER EXPECT
FAST RIGHT VOTE.
YES RECALL WATCHING EIGHTY TO
EIGHTY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
JONES SAWYER. AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY AYE AYE LACKEY AYE
CORREO.
CORREO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY. QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
CABLE PASSES
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO. VOTE ONLY.
AB SIXTEEN. COOPER CRIMINAL LAW.
DNA EVIDENCE.
THERE IT DOES NOT WE ARE HAD
TESTIMONY SO IT DOESN'T REQUIRE.
ANY TESTIMONY.
THIS CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE.
HAS GIVEN.
QUITE A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MAKE THE BILL BETTER.
SO NOT ONLY WOULD BE BETTER FOR
THIS HOUSE WILL BE ABLE.
PASS ON THE OTHER.
SITE.
I WILL CONTINUE.
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR.
AS I HAVE IN THE PAST.
GIVING NUMEROUS AND I REPEAT
NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES.
OFFER AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL SO
WE COULD MOVE IT FORWARD.
I AM GOING TO.
RECOMMEND AT WE MOVE THIS OUT OF
THIS HOUSE.
OTHERS COMMITTEE.
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO DEBATE.
AUNT A BE SIXTEEN TO PROMOTE LAW
DNA EVIDENCE.
WITH THAT.
WHO RECALL ROLE?
AB SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY. LACKEY AYE CORREO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY QUIRK.
RESERVING MY VOTE ON THE FLOOR
ALL VOTE I NOW.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
BILLS ON CALL NICHE ONE.
MISTER COOPER.
AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE PETTY THEFT
AND SUBSEQUENT CONVICTIONS.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MISTER COOPER.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN PROP FORTY
SEVEN WAS PASSED BY BALLOT
INITIATIVE. FORTY SEVEN REMOVED
THE LEGAL REMEDY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT APPREHEND AND
PROSECUTE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
INTENT ON COMMITTING THEFT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
ACCORDING THE CALIFORNIA PARTNER
JUSTICE THE MONETARY VALUE STILL
PROPERTY IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
APPROACH TO POINT PARK TO PLAY
FIVE BILLION.
MARK INCREASE FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
TO ILLUSTRATE THIS POINT A LARGE
GROCERY STORE CHAIN REPORTED
THAT TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
THEY'RE COVERED ALMOST A HUNDRED
SIXTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH
THE STORE PROPERTY FROM THIEVES.
THE POINT OF THEFT
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE SAME CHAIN
REPORT THAT RECOVERY IN THE
AMOUNT OF JUST OVER FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AS A TO FORTY PERCENT INCREASE
OF NO FAST IN THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD FROM WHEN RETAIL CHAIN.
THIS PROBLEM ESPECIALLY WRECKING
HAVOC R. SMALLER MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES DIRECTLY SERVING MORE
AFFORDABLE NEIGHBORHOODS. AS AN
EXAMPLE ONE SMALLER SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GROCERY CHAIN
REPORTED THAT TWENTY THIRTEEN
THEY'RE COVERED ALMOST.
NINE HUNDRED NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN WITH A TALL POPPY
FROM THIEVES THE POINT OF THEFT.
INTO SIXTEEN THE SAME CHAIN
REPORT THAT RECOVERING THEM OUT
JUST OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IS THERE UNDER THIRTY PERCENT
INCREASE OF KNOWN FAST ME A
THREE YEAR PERIOD FROM A SMALL
RETAIL CHAIN.
SINCE LOST CHANGE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN SERIAL THIEVES OF
REALIZE THAT THEY CAN STILL UP
TO NINE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
PER INCIDENT.
IN BE HELD TOO LITTLE OR NO
CONSEQUENCES.
AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE FOCUSES ON
CURBING THIS RIP ITSELF PROBLEM
BY FOCUSING ON THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE REPEAT OFFENDERS.
AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE CREATING
WHILE THERE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF THREE OR MORE
FAST.
FOR CEREAL THEFT OF THE AMOUNT
OF NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS INCREASE
A PATH TO HELP THOSE WHO MAY
SUFFER SOME SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROBLEMS.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE WILL GIVE
THE COURT THE DISCRETION TO
SNIFF THE CONVICTION OF SERIAL
THEFT AND COMPLETELY ERASE THE
ARREST OF ANY INDIVIDUAL. WHO
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE A COURT
ORDERED DRUG OR ALCOHOL BE REAL
REHABILITATION PROGRAM
FINALLY ABA SIMPLIFIED MUST GO
TO THE VOTERS FOR APPROVAL?
FORTUNATELY WITNESSES TODAY JAVA
FELDMAN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND
AIR MARINO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION.
FILM.
CHAIR MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION.
.
CO SPONSORS THE MEASURE. NOT
SPENT THE LAST THREE MONTHS TORN
THE STATE DOING LEGISLATIVE
UPDATES FOR POLICE CHIEFS FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
EVERYWHERE I WENT THAT EVERY
SINGLE POLICE CHIEF STORIES OF
THIS IMPACT BEING REAL IN THEIR
COMMUNITY THE FACT THAT THE LAWS
INSUFFICIENT ALL TO THE BEHAVIOR
OF THESE CAREER CRIMINALS THAT
REALIZE THAT THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE.
OF.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THAT WAS
MEANT FOR LOW LEVEL OFFENDERS IT
WAS NOT MEANT FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS. WHEN YOU TALK TO THE
CITY COUNCILS.
AND THE ELECTED IN THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
THEY WHEN THEY REALIZE IT TOO
AND WE TALK TO THE PUBLIC WE
WE'VE LOOKED AT OF OPINIONS ON
THIS MATTER.
I THERE IS NOT SUPPORT TAKE
CREATE LAWS THAT TREAT.
REPEAT OFFENDERS THE SAME AS
THAT FIRST TIME LOW LEVEL
OFFENDER. WHICH IS WHY WE'VE
CRAFTED THIS TO BE.
TARGETED FOCUSING PRIMARILY ON
REPEAT OFFENDERS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS WORK BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT THE LAW USED TO BE
THIS OF WHAT WE USED AS A TOOL
TO GO AFTER THE FOLKS WERE
CREATING MOST OF THE PROBLEMS.
AND WAS EFFECTIVE SO GOING BACK
TO IT IS.
.
IS IT IS.
SOME THAT WE KNOW WILL WORK AND
BE A IMPACT FALL FOR THIS ISSUE
YOU KNOW THE DIVERSION PIECE IS
ALSO.
.
BECAUSE WE REALIZE THAT THERE
ARE FOLKS OUT THERE THAT HAVE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROBLEMS ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS THAT NEED TO BE. A
TAKEN CARE OF THROUGH TREATMENT
RATHER THAN PUNISHMENT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE INCLUDED THAT
PIECE YOU KNOW THERE WERE SOME
QUESTIONS THAT. OFFICERS HAD
ABOUT WHY ALLOW IT FOR THE THIRD
TIME OFFENDER NOT THE FIRST TIME
OFFENDER. YOU KNOW DA'S CAN
ALREADY ALLOW DIVERSION FOR
FIRST TIME OFFENDERS THAT'S
ALREADY AVAILABLE FOR GOING
ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT HERE.
SOMEONE THAT HAS NOT BEEN DONE
BEFORE TO GIVE IT FOR REPEAT
OFFENDERS IS WE DO UNDERSTAND
THE SERIOUSNESS OF A.
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ADDICTION.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS A
TAILORED APPROACH AT FIXING AN
IDENTIFIED PROBLEM IT'S NOT
UNDOING.
PROP FORTY SEVEN ITS NOT TRYING
TO GO BACK TO SYSTEM MASS
INCARCERATION NO POLICE CHIEF IN
THE STATE WANTS THAT WAS
ADVOCATING FOR THAT.
BUT EVERY CHIEF THAT I'VE TALKED
TO.
REALIZES THAT THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE FACING IS BECAUSE OF THE
THE REFORM THAT WE'VE HAD AND WE
NEED CLEAN UP PIECES OF IT. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE PUSHING FOR
WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU MR FELLOW.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AYE AARON
MORENO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROWERS ASSOCIATION.
TO ECHO.
WHICH FILMS STATEMENT.
YOU'LL NEVER ONE PRIORITY WHEN
TALKING GROSS AROUND THE STATE
IS DEALING WITH WITH THE
INCREASED LOSSES. AND THAT OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE HAD TO
DEAL WITH.
IN RECENT YEARS.
YOU KNOW WHERE'S CONSTITUENTS I
MEAN MUCH LIKE CONSTITUENTS
COME.
LOOKING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM.
AS IMAGE YOU WERE COMING AS
CONSTITUENTS ASKING. THE
LECHEROUS TO. OH MY KNOW MISTER
CHAIR YOU'VE SAID.
IN THE PAST WITH OTHER BILLS.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A PROBLEM I
THINK WE ALL REALIZE THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM AND AND IT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
WE BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY
DISCREET FIX WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
TO UNDO.
ANY PREVIOUS INITIATIVES AS YOU
AND I HAVE DISCUSSED IN THE PAST
THAT'S NOT OUR INTENT.
WE THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
FOCUSED.
SOLUTION TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM.
IN TERMS OF YOUR LOSSES AS
MISTER COOPER.
CITED IN A STATEMENT OF OUR
COMPANIES HAVE SEEN LOSSES FROM
TWENTY TWELVE TO DO TO PRESENT
TIME THAT THAT HAVE BEEN IN SOME
CASES ONE HUNDRED. AND FIFTY
PERCENT ALMOST IN A PERCENT
INCREASE IN LOSSES THAT.
OUR COMPANIES ARE FINDING OUT
THE DOOR AND MIND YOU THAT'S
ONLY WHAT THE CATCH NOT DOOR I
MEAN THAT'S THAT'S A PERCENTAGE
OF. WHAT'S BEING LOST
ALTOGETHER.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS SHOULD BE
A TOOL.
NOT ONLY TO ADDRESS.
THE PROBLEM AFTER THE CRIME'S
OCCURRED BUT WE ALSO THINK IT
SHOULD BE A DETERRENT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE COME IN THERE JUST
EMBOLDENED THEY JUST COME IN AND
AND. KNOWING THAT LAW IS HELD AS
THEY JUST THINK THEY HAVE
LICENSE TO COME IN AND TAKE TAKE
STUFF.
YOU MAY RECALL LAST YEAR THERE
WAS A SECURITY GUARD AT A FOOD
LISTEN CELLMARK.
KILLED.
BY SOMEBODY COMING IN.
THINKING THAT THEY HAVE LICENSE
TO THIS BECAUSE THE LAW HAS AS
IN SKIN YOU KNOW IN A PASSIVE
WAY GIVEN THEM PERMISSION TO DO
THIS WITH NO CONSEQUENCES.
INSTEAD OF JUST GO LAST YEAR
THERE WAS A WORKER STABBED.
BY SOMEBODY COMING AND TRYING TO
TAKE STUFF.
IN OAK GROVE ACTUALLY MISTER
COOPER'S DISTRICT I WAS IN A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO THERE WAS AN
ELDERLY WOMAN GOT. I BELIEVE SHE
WAS KILLED AT A CVS ARTICLES A
WALGREEN'S IN LAGUNA.
BY THIEVES YOU CAME IN.
BUT THEY COULD STEAL RUNNING UP
BURDEN AWAY THEY KNOCKED OVER
THE KILTER.
NO NO. THAT'S NOT GONNA SOLVE
SOME THESE MORE VIOLENT FOLKS I
GET THAT A SEPARATE CRIME BUT
THE FACT THAT PEOPLE NOW KNOW.
THAT YOU CAN TAKE UP TO NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY. BENNETT'S.
LOW RISK HIGH REWARD AYE I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU VIDEOS OF PEOPLE
LITERALLY. WHO COME IN THERE AND
TRY TO HIDE IT THE PHILIPPA A
BASKET WITH WITH BEER OR LIQUOR
OR MEET AND JUST? WALK OUT THE
DOOR. I'VE HAD SOME STORIES
WHERE SOME OF OUR STORES WILL
SAY THAT PEOPLE NOW JUST FLIP
OFF. AS A WALK A DOG IS A KNOW
NOTHING IS DONE.
AGAIN YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
PANACEA THIS IS NOT TO BE A
MAGIC BULLET TO FIX ALL THESE
PROBLEMS THAT BEING SAID IF
THERE'S A TOOL THAT. NOT ONLY
CAN DEAL WITH THOSE WHO ARE
DOING THIS REPEATEDLY WHICH
AGAIN. THIS WOULD ONLY BE
APPLIED TO SOME WHO'S DOING OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AND OVER. BUT
IF WE CAN PREVENT SOME LEASE ON
THE FRONT END.
WE HELPED LOSSES WE HELP WITH
WORKER SAFETY.
AND WE THINK THIS IS A SENSIBLE
APPROACH THAT THAT PUTS ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE POCKET OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO TO HELP PREVENT
AND AND DEAL WITH THESE PROBLEMS
AND. WITH THAT RESPECT THE
ASTEROID VOTE AND SOME POSITIVE
SITUATION WHEN THE BILL IS IS A
CONTRIBUTOR THINKS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS SHOT
UNDER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION EXPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOING TURN MEMBERS THEIR GOLF
WITH LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHEN MISS SHARON CHANNEL THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORNING MRCHAIRMAN SHANE LIVING
ON BEHALF OF CSL THE A FO P.
ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE COUNTY
DEPUTY SHERIFF SACRAMENTO
DERBYSHIRE ASSOCIATIONAL LONG
BEACH POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO IT WAS THE LEVEL.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MORNING
I'M KATHY SURE SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
NEARLY SIXTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS VOTED IN FAVOR
OF PROP FORTY SEVEN REDUCING THE
PENALTIES FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PETTY CRIMES.
PROP 47-57 PENALTIES FOR THEFT
VALUED AT NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS OR LESS AND NARROWED THE
LIST OF PRIOR OFFENSES WHICH
MAKE SOMEONE ELIGIBLE TO BE
PROSECUTED FOR PETTY THEFT WITH
THE PRIOR.
A CENTRAL PART OF THE PURPOSE OF
PROP FORTY SEVEN WAS STIRRED
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF NON VIOLENT
OFFENDERS IN CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISONS.
IT HAS FULFILL THAT PURPOSE AND
HAS DONE SO WITHOUT PUTTING
PUBLIC SAFETY AT RISK.
APPROPRIATE PENALTIES REMAIN
AVAILABLE FOR PERSONS CONVICTED
OF THE PETTY CRIMES ADDRESSED IN
A BEAST EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
INCLUDING SIGNIFICANT JAIL TIME
FOR REPEAT THEFT OFFENSES.
ANY EXCUSE ME.
IN RECENT NUMBER SHOWS RECENT
NUMBERS SHOW THAT AFTER A BRIEF
PERIOD OF INCREASE.
THEFT CRIMES AND ESPECIALLY
SHOPLIFTING ARE ONCE AGAIN
DECREASING THERE SIMPLY NO NEED
TO REVISIT THE WISE CHOICE MADE
BY VOTERS IN ENACTING PROP FORTY
SEVEN.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN RECENT YEARS IN
RESHAPING ITS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
TO SAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
PREVIOUSLY WASTED ON COSTLY
OVERLY HARSH CRIMINAL SENTENCES.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE ON THIS PATH
RATHER THAN TURNING BACK THE
CLOCK WE ARE JR NO VOTE ON AB
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SOME IN
OPPOSITION.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS IN THAT BROKE OUT HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR.
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
LACKEY.
YEAH I'D JUST LIKE TO MAKE OVER
A REMARKS YOU KNOW. WITH THE
RECENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP FORTY
SEVEN WE KNOW THAT.
RETAILERS HAVE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN WHAT WE
CALL. WHAT WE CALL PETTY THEFT?
AND I KNOW THAT.
MANY MANY MANY OF THESE
OFFENDERS.
HAVE TAKEN THIS NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLAR THRESHOLD.
PER INCIDENT.
WHICH.
.
HAS BEEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND IT.
IN MANY INSTANCES UNFORTUNATELY
THIS IS BECOMING A WIDESPREAD
PROBLEM IN ALMOST EVERY
COMMUNITY THAT THAT I'M AWARE
OF.
AND THE PROBLEM HAS BECOME
ANYTHING BUT.
AND I THINK WHEN WE PASSED PROP
FORTY SEVEN WE NEVER REALLY
CONSIDERED THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME SOPHISTICATION.
AND THAT AT THIS BECOME A VERY
SERIOUS THREAT TO RETELL.
AND I I COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S A SIMPLE REMEDY FOR A
VERY VERY BIG PROBLEM.
ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS.
TO COOPER YOU MAY CLOSE THAT
MISTER CHAIR AND POINT OUT
THINGS BE COMMITTEE SO YOU
TALKED ABOUT THEIR SIGNIFICANT.
MEMORIES RIGHT NOW UPLAND OTHER
COMMITTEE REPORT IT TALKS ABOUT
CURRENT LAW PERMITS AGGREGATION
THE THEFT OFFENSES.
THAT IS WRONG.
OKAY IT'S INACCURATE AND I'LL
TELL YOU COUPLE THINGS WHY.
.
COVERS COVERS PRE COURT RECENTLY
RULED IN PEOPLE VERSUS PAGE BUT
EVEN STILL IN THE MOTOR VEHICLE.
UNDER NINE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
A MISDEMEANOR FEW DRIVE THE
VEHICLE THAT IS UNDER NOT A
FIFTY DOLLARS CHANCES ARE EITHER
ELDERLY. POOR ON A FIXED INCOME
UNEMPLOYED OR WORKING ON A
MINIMUM WAGE JOB IT'S REALLY CAN
AFFORD TO LOSE THOSE REALLY
MEANS THE TRANSPORTATION RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A MISDEMEANOR.
SO WE CAME IN RECENTLY WITH THE
FORCE CHECK INTO A BANK HEALTH
LESSON NINE FIFTY.
THE SUPREME COURT RULED IS A
MISDEMEANOR.
IN TWO RECENT CASES.
A DISK ATTORNEYS TRIED AG THEFT.
AN ATTORNEY GENERAL KAMEL HARRIS
WROTE BRIEFS SUBMITTED IN THE
COURTS AND THEY'RE NOW MATTERS
OF RECORD.
SLOW COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT CASE
PEOPLE VERSUS CHENEY THE VICTIMS
OF THE GAP.
CASUAL MALE AND ALTHOUGH
FOR ROUGHLY YOU KNOW RUN ABOUT
NINE FIFTY.
AND HERE'S A QUOTE FROM ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
THE APPELLANT THE CONVICT
INDIVIDUALS ELIGIBLE FOR RECENT
SINGER PROP FORTY SEVEN BECAUSE
THE VITAL STOLEN PROPERTY
CHARGING SEPARATE COUNTS MAY NOT
BE AGGREGATED.
THE TRIAL COURT ERRED WHEN
DENIED HER PETITION BY
AGGREGATING THE VALUE STILL
IMPROPERLY INTO SHOPLIFTING
COUNTS.
PROP 47-57 FOR RECEIVING STOLEN
PROPERTY TREES A TOTAL OF NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS.
IN A SEPARATE CASE IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT PEOPLE
VERSUS WALLACE THE PROSECUTION
ATTEMPTED TO AGGREGATE THE
CRIMES RECEIVING STOLEN
PROPERTY.
AND FUNCTIONS OF CREDIT CARDS
THE VICTIMS WERE MALL MARTIN
CHEVRON.
HERE THE QUOTES
THE TRIAL COURT ERRED BY
AGGREGATING THE LOSS OF MOUNT
FROM SEVERAL COUNTS.
THE APPELLANT ARGUES THE TRIAL
COURT ERRED BUT CONSIDERING THE
AGGIE. LOSSES FROM ALL COUNTS
INCLUDING THOSE THAT WERE
DISMISSED.
THE COCK TRIAL COURT WAS NOT
PERMITTED TO AGGREGATE THE TOTAL
LOSS FOR MULTIPLE COUNTS.
DETERMINE WHETHER THE NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS FISH
WITHIN REACH THREE OF AN OPINION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL THAT IS CASE LAW AS LAW
RIGHT NOW. IS THAT YOU CAN'T
AGGREGATE.
SO HILL AWFUL TALKING ABOUT
AGGREGATION COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
IT DOESN'T WORK
AS FAR OWN ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
SO THIS IS CASE LAW RIGHT NOW
THIS IS NOT SOMEONE TO
SUMMARIZING STEPPING UP.
SO YOU CAN ALBEIT THEFT SO ONE
PROP FORTY SEVEN WAS PASSED.
THESE THINGS ARE NEVER TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT ABSOLUTELY NOT. NO
NEVER SAID THAT A STOLEN CAR.
YOU STILL SOMEONE'S CAR STILL
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE RICH YOU CAL
EXPENSIVE PART BUT IF YOUR POOR
YOUR CARS.
IN EXPENSIVE IT'S A MISDEMEANOR.
SOURCE THE LESSER OF A CRIME
I'LL NEVER INTENDED BY THE
VOTERS. COMING A PASSING
FRAUDULENT CHECK BECAUSE LESSEN
NIGHT FIFTY.
I WAS NEVER INTENDEDBY THE
VOTERS AND THAT'S WE WILL HE
COMES DOWN TO WHO'S AFFECTS IS
MAMA POP RETAILERS FOLKS WALKING
IN. INTO IN A NEIGHBORHOOD A%
UNDERSERVED NEIGHBORHOOD
GRABBING CIGARETTES ALCOHOL FOOD
AND WALKING OUT WITH IT.
THOSE PISTOLS R. CAN AFFORD TO
REPLACE THAT LET'S WE WHOSE
AFFECTING AFFECTING MEMBERS HEAR
US IN THIS BUILDING AFFECTING
POOR PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHO'S
PAYING MORE BECAUSE THE
RETAILERS. PASS ON THE COSTS THE
GUY REGAIN THEIR COST SOMEWHERE
TO THE CONSUMERS. IN THOSE
SECOND FOR THE ARE BEING DAMAGED
THE MOST.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A COMMON
SENSE MIDDLE GROUND THAT FOCUSES
ON REPEAT OFFENDERS.
OFFERS HELP TO THOSE WITH DOZENS
OF THESE PROBLEMS IT PROTECTS
THE CONSUMER.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE PROVIDE
SENSIBLE SOLUTIONS TO THE RISING
LOSS OF PROPERTY BY REPEAT
OFFENDERS.
GET THEM HELP.
AND ALSO THE BIG ISSUE IS A LOT
IS CRIMES ARE UNDER REPORTED
PEOPLE DON'T FILE REPORTS.
YOUR CARD IS BROKEN INTO. LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILDLIFE ALL REPORT
WILL INVESTIGATE CAR BREAK INS
AND INVESTIGATE FEST LIKE THAT
LEADER MISDEMEANORS.
AND FOR SOMEONE SIT HERE AND SAY
SOME OF THOSE TO GO TO STATE
PRISON. ON MISDEMEANORS IS VERY
DISINGENUOUS IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
MISDEMEANOR SO I DON'T CARE WHAT
IT IS YOU'RE THE STATE PRISON
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENING.
PRISON IS RESERVE FOR SERIOUS
OFFENDERS NOT MISDEMEANOR
OFFENDERS.
COUNTY JAIL THE SAME THING.
WE HAVE THE THE VERSE THE WORST
IN THERE THAT'S A BIG ISSUE WITH
THIS IS A PROBLEM AND NOW WITH
DRUG COURT. FULL ALLERGIC
CORDLESS YOU WANNA GET.
YOUR REST.
YOU KNOW ADJUDICATED BECAUSE YOU
ARE JOB OTHERWISE DRUG COURT
KNOWN BUILDING WAS NO HAMMER.
BECAUSE DRUGS THE HARDEST THING
TO GET OFF OF HIM BEFORE DRUGS
HAVE HAMMER TO FOR SOMEONE TO
GOING TO DRUG COURT AND GET
CLEANED UP THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
ANYMORE.
SO WE NEED TO FIX THIS WE'VE ALL
ADMIT THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH IT.
AND ONE DENIAL HERE BUT.
AGGREGATION.
IN THE FOLKS THAT SAY CAN BE
AGGREGATED.
NONE OTHER TALK ABOUT RESPECT
YASSER AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
COOPER AND.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
THAT. THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE IT
IS A PROBLEM BUT. I DO GENERALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM
AND SO SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WHAT WE DISAGREE IS ON
METHODOLOGY? AND I THINK IF WE
ALL GOT INTO THE SAME ROOM AND
DISGUSTED.
WITH ALL LEVELS OF RHETORIC
DOWN.
THAT WE CAN COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION. THAT AND I'M GLAD THAT
YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO GO BACK TO
PROP FORTY SEVEN THAT'S THAT'S
VERY ENCOURAGING. THAT WE CAN WE
CAN COME UP WITH A SOLUTION ARM
MAYBE VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
MISTER COOPER IS RECOMMENDING.
ON THE CHAIR UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT
NOW RECKONING A NO VOTE BECAUSE
I THINK WE NEED TO COME BACK TO
THE TABLE. AND DISCUSS IT SOME
MORE.
IS THERE A MOTION.
WITH THE BILL.
THERE'S A MOTION AND IS NO
SECOND.
THE BILL DOES.
PHILIP FOR LACK OF A SECOND.
ITEM NUMBER.
I'M LOOKING FOR AUTHORS.
MR GARCIA MISTER ALAN.
MISC GONZALEZ FLETCHER
.
THERE'S MR EDUARDO.
GARCIA.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
BUT DOING AB TWELVE SIXTY TO.
CALIFORNIA GANG CRIME AND
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM.
THE GAMES CHAIRED MEMBERS THIS
IS ANY AVAIL DISTRICT BILL.
SIMPLE BILL THAT AD SAYS BORDER
TOWN OF CALEXICO. TO THE LIST OF
CITIES THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY BE
I'LL DOUBLE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
GANG CRIME AND VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
HE MOVED.
HAVE A QUESTION.
LET HIM FINISH.
AT.
AND SUPPORT YES MISS CHAIR RYAN
CHAIRMAN OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION.
CLICK SCHOOLS IN OUR COUNTY AND
WE STRONGLY URGE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
FED ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE OUT THERE IN
OPPOSITION.
MEAN THAT MR LACKEY HAS A
QUESTION.
YEAH I'M I FULLY INTEND TO
SUPPORT THE BILL BUT I WAS
CURIOUS AS YOUR. ANY.
BUDGET REQUEST AT ALL THAT'S
COUPLED WITH THIS BILL OR ANY.
INTENTION TO REINVIGORATE ANY
KIND OF FINANCING FOR THIS BILL
THERE WILL BE AND.
HAPPY TO.
HAVE YOU JOIN US IN THAT EFFORT
THAT TOO INSURE THAT THERE'S
FUNDING. AVAILABLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND FOR THE ELIGIBLE
CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS HIGH INCIDENCE. OF.
CRIME MAG GANG VIOLENCE. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES EXIST.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS ARE WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
CHAIRED RECOMMENDED AYE YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASTURE APPROPRIATIONS
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JOHN SIR
AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE CORREO.
CORREO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY. QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
BILL PASSES THANK YOU CHECK THAT
YOU.
SO WE'RE STILL WAITING. ON TO
MORE ITEMS.
BABY THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR MISTER
TRAVIS ALLEN FIREARMS CONCEALED.
KERRY LICENSES.
AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR GONZALEZ
FLETCHER FROM A LAW DNA
COLLECTION MINERS
MISTER ALAN.
HAVE YOU SEE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR TRAVIS ALLEN
FIREARMS CONCEALED CARRY
LICENSES.
THEY.
BEAR
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
SAY TO PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR WHICH WILL
STANDARDIZE R. STATEWIDE
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT PROCESS
BY STATING THAT IF AN INDIVIDUAL
FULFILLS THE NECESSARY
REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA SHALL ISSUE THEIR
LICENSE.
FURTHER WOULD ALLOW SOMEONE WITH
A VALID CCW TO CARRY THEIR
PERSONAL PROTECTION FIREARMS
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
VIOLENT CRIME IS BEEN INCREASING
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE PASSAGE%
MAYBE ONE OR NINE PROP FORTY
SEVEN AND PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
WITH VIOLENT CRIME A FIFTEEN
POINT FOUR PERCENT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ALONE MORE
MORE CALIFORNIANS ARE CHOOSING
TO TAKE ACTION. TO APPLY FOR CCW
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES AS A WAY
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR LOVED
ONES.
AS ASSISTANCE DANCE A CALIFORNIA
CAN BE ISSUED OR DENIED TO
CONCEAL CARRY PERMITS BASED
SOLELY ON WHERE THEY LIVE SINCE
LOCAL SHERIFF'S SET THEIR OWN
STANDARDS FOR LICENSING. ENTIRE
COUNTIES ARE SUBJECT TO
POLITICAL PRESSURE THAT IS PUT
ON THAT SURE BY THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. BECAUSE OF THIS
MANY COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
VIRTUALLY NO CONCEALED CARRY
LICENSES GRANTED LEAVING ALL OF
THEIR RESIDENTS AT RISK.
FOR EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALONE THERE OVER TEN
MILLION RESIDENTS GET THEIR ONLY
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE CCW
PERMITS.
IN THAT COUNTY.
PUTTING UP ROADBLOCKS FOR LAWFUL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
THESE ARE RESIDENTS EXCUSE ME
PUTTING UP ROAD BLOCKS FOR
LAWFUL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES IS WRONG.
THESE RESIDENTS WHO ARE WILLING
TO WORK THROUGH A LENGTHY
APPLICATION PROCESS AN EDUCATION
PROCESS AS WELL AS TO HEAR TO
STATE REGULATIONS JUST TO OBTAIN
THEIR LICENSE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY.
IS WRONG.
CALIFORNIANS MUST HAVE THE RIGHT
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES NOT ONLY
IN THEIR HOME. BUT WHEN THEY
WALK DOWN OUR STREETS.
NO GUN LAW IN THE NATION WILL
DETER ANYONE WHO'S ALREADY SET
ON BREAKING OUR LAWS.
ILLEGALLY ACQUIRING WEAPONS
OR ASSAULTING ANOTHER
CALIFORNIAN. BY DENYING CCW
APPLICATIONS.
WE ARE ONLY HURTING INNOCENT
CALIFORNIANS WHO DESERVE A RIGHT
TO FEEL SAFE INNOCENT
CALIFORNIANS WHO DOES NOT
DESERVE THE RIGHT TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR LOVED
ONES. AGAIN NOT ONLY THEIR HOMES
BUT WHEN THEY WALK ANYWHERE IN
ANY OF CALIFORNIA STREETS.
TRAGEDIES HAVE BEEN AFFECTING
EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIAN WITH
THE RISE IN VIOLENT CRIME.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIANS THE RIGHT TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES.
WITHOUT I HAVE BROUGHT A COUPLE
OF EXPERTS AND I'D LIKE THEM TO
ALSO TESTIFY AS TO THE NEED FOR
HAVING A SHALL ISSUE PERMITTING
PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA FOR CW'S.
YEAH.
WHO WHERE ONLY AGAIN FIRST?
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD THE
AND READ THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALLEN FOR
BRINGING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION HERE TODAY.
AS WE'VE TALKEDIN THIS
COMMITTEE.
OVER THE YEARS THURSDAY
INEQUITABLE NATURE TO
CALIFORNIA'S CONCEALED CARRY
LAWS THE GOOD CAUSE REQUIREMENT.
IS APPLIED DIFFERENTLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE
FEEL THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN
EVERY LAW BY THE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME RIGHT TO
SELF DEFENSE REGARDLESS OF
WHERE.
THEY LIVE WHETHER IT'S IN
SACRAMENTO LA SAN FRANCISCO
MODOK.
WE FEEL THAT THERE SHOULD BE
CONSISTENT STANDARD. AND
CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT HOLDERS
NOT ONLY IN THIS STATE BUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY HAVE
PROVEN TO BE JUST THAT LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS WE SEEM TO BUY
ONE DECREASE IN VIOLENT CRIME.
AS THE RATE OF PERMITS HAVE GONE
UP NATIONWIDE THERE'S MORE THAN
SIXTEEN MILLION CONCEALED CARRY
PERMITS.
HOLDERS IN THE COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
SO WHAT THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES IS
IT MAKES OUR CCW PERMITTING
SYSTEM FAIR. IT LEAVES ALL THE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE AS
FAR AS CRIMINAL BACKGROUNDS
TRAINING EXETER AND JUST MAKES
IT A FAIR PROCESS SO THAT SOME
PERSONS ARE NOT GIVEN
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT OVER
OTHERS IN THEIR INHERENT RIGHT
TO SELF DEFENSE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRAIG LIVES WITH A MAP
OF THE FIREARMS POLICY COALITION
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S GUN
CONTROL LAWS HAVE LARGELY BEEN
DISCRIMINATORY WHETHER IT WAS. A
AB EIGHTY IN THE IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY FOUR WHICH SPECIFICALLY
SOUGHT TO KEEP AMMUNITION AND
FIREARMS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
INDIANS BUT THEN THERE'S THE
HOUSE ACT OF NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR. WHICH AMONG OTHER THINGS
PREVENTED.
HISPANICS AND CHINESE FOR BEING
ABLE TO PURCHASE FIREARMS UP BUT
ALSO AMENDED THE CONCEALED CARRY
LAW IN ORDER TO MAKE IT SUCH
THAT IT'S DISCRETIONARY.
IN OTHER WORDS THAT DIED THEN
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT COULD THEN
ARBITRARILY DECIDE WHO COULD AND
COULD NOT GET A PERMIT.
AYE AND WE SEEN UNFORTUNATELY WE
SEE THAT DISCRIMINATION PLAYING
ITSELF OUT EVEN TODAY AS WAS
MENTIONED ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN PERMITS.
IN ALL OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY A
SKI COUNTING OF OVER TEN MILLION
PEOPLE WHAT WASN'T POINTED OUT
WAS THAT ONLY NINE OF THOSE
PERMITS WERE TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT RELATED TO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY. MEANING
THAT AND IF YOU WERE NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT YOU WERE NOT ABLE OR
YOU DID NOT HAVE SUFFICIENT GOOD
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN A PERMIT. I FIND THAT TO
BE A BEYOND THE DISCRIMINATORY
THE THING IS THAT IF YOU ARE A
LAW ABIDING CITIZEN.
IF YOU ARE A CITIZEN WAS
DEMONSTRATED AN ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE LAW
RELATING TO USE OF FORCE
UNDERSTAND HOW TO SAFELY UTILIZE
YOUR FIREARM.
THEN AND GONE THROUGH ALL OF
THE TESTS IN THE THINGS THAT YOU
NEED TO IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN A PERMIT. THEN YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE AND ALLOW TO EXCESS
EXERCISE YOUR CONSTITUTIONALLY
ENUMERATED RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HAPPY
NEW YEAR. INTERESTING TO BE BACK
HERE AGAIN. AND THE IT WILL BE
AN INTERESTING YEAR I'M SURE
SEPARATE IS REPRESENTING GUN
OWNERS CALIFORNIA COUPLE THINGS
I WANNA.
POINT OUT THAT.
MY COLLEAGUES BRIEFLY TOUCHED
ON.
AGAIN. CCW HOLDERS NATIONWIDE
ARE THE MOST LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS.
OF ALL CITIZENS OF ALL COMMUNITY
SUBGROUPS OF ANYBODY THEY ARE
THE MOST LAW ABIDING WHY
WOULDN'T THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WANTING INCREASE THAT NUMBER. OF
OF OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE PROVEN TO
BE LAW ABIDING NOW THIS DOESN'T.
STRIP LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM
DISCRETION THEY STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY IF THEY IDENTIFY
SOMEBODY WHO IS OF.
BAD MORAL CHARACTER THEY CAN
STILL DENY THAT APPLICATION.
BUT THAT THAT CONSTANTLY IS
CONSEQUENT TO TO UP.
SOMETHING THAT THAT PERSON HAS
DONE TO LOSE THEIR THEIR THE
WRITER THEIR ABILITY TO. TO TO
GET A CONCEALED FIREARM.
YOU KNOW SOMEBODY IN IN MEADOW
VIEW.
WHO HAS A CONCEALED WEAPONS
PERMIT AND STATED CALIFORNIA?
WHO NEEDS A PERMIT?
IN THIS DETERRENT TO LIVE WHERE
THEY LIVE IS NO DIFFERENT THAN
SOMEBODY WHO LIVES IN EAST LOS
ANGELES WHERE I GREW UP WHO
CANNOT GET A PERMIT.
OR WHAT'S SPUR CRENSHAW.
OR OR.
YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW PORTIONS OF OF OF SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WHO CANNOT.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
RIGHTS THAT THEY HAVE? AND THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THEM OR THE MOST
LAW ABIDING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN LAST YEAR IN IN
IN A COMMITTEE HERE YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU WE WE LIKE
OUR CALIFORNIA LOS. AND WE WANT
TO TO.
YOU KNOW FOR PEOPLE TO.
AND ABIDE BY THE LAWS SO WHY
NOT.
OPEN THIS.
US SYSTEM UP SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
COMPLY WITH THE LAW AND ABIDE BY
THOSE LAWS.
WOULD WE FEEL THAT THIS IS A.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THING FOR
FAIRNESS.
FOR EQUALITY.
.
AND AND FRANKLY THERE THE THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM THE
MOST ARE THE ONES WHO CANNOT.
GET THEM BECAUSE OF THE
ARBITRARY POLICIES
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
USE OF LARGELY DICTATED BY.
POLITICAL PRESSURES AND NOBODY'S
RIGHTS SHOULD BE DICTATED BY
POLITICAL PRESSURES WE WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLYMAN FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. THIS TRULY IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS.
EQUAL PROTECTION BILL.
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO EVERY LAW
ABIDING CITIZEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEM WOULD GO A LONG
WAYS.
TO.
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES IN AN EVER GROWING
DANGEROUS SITUATION I JUST HEARD
ON THE WAY IN.
THE WAS REPORT OF VIOLENT CRIME
AND GUN DEATHS THROUGHOUT
AMERICA OR DOWN.
THEY'VE GONE DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
CASH THAT'S NOT HAPPEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S A SHAME IN THIS BILL
COULD GO A LONG WAYS TO HELP IN
THAT SO THANK YOU SENTIMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE ROY GRIFFITH
ON THE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA RIFLE
PISTOL ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN EQUAL
RIGHTS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU.
JIM MCMAHON STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN GREEN WOOD FIREARMS TRAINER
CCW INSTRUCTOR FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS.
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THESE ARE GOOD PEOPLE. THEY DO
NOT BREAK THE LAW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING HAPPY
NEW YEAR.
HERE YOU I'M AMANDA WILCOX I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA%
CHAPTERS OF THE BRADY CAMPAIGN
TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE LOST.
LOVELAND GUNFIRE.
INCLUDING MYSELF.
TOMORROW SEVENTEENTH. UNIVERSE
FREE OF MY DAUGHTER'S DEATH
FINISHED SHOOTING RAMPAGE.
SO I FEEL.
LITTLE BIT EMOTIONAL THIS WEEK.
THIS BILL AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FOUR.
HAS BEEN TRIED THE POLICIES BEEN
TRIED MANY TIMES IN CALIFORNIA.
I'VE MET MANY LETTERS THE
SUBJECT ON THE BILL HAS FAILED
AND.
I HOPE IT WILL AGAIN THIS YEAR.
THE KEY ISSUE IS SHOULD
CALIFORNIA BECOME. A SHALL ISSUE
STATE IN TERMS OF ISSUING CCW
PERMITS WHERE ESSENTIALLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOSE THEIR
DISCRETION RP LEAST PART OF
THEIR DISCRETION IN ISSUE THE
CCW BECAUSE IT REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT OF HAVING TO THAT
BECAUSE.
SO SHOULD SOMEONE BE ABLE TO
CARRY A LOADED HANDGUN PUBLIC
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO.
OR SHOULD THEY HAVE A NEED FOR
DOING THAT.
I WOULD OFFER THATSOMEONE
CARRYING A LOADED.
HITTING GUN IN PUBLIC PUTS
OTHERS AT RISK IN IS NOT IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
UP WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT IS THE
DECISION TO SHOOT.
OR NOT TO SHOOT ASSASSIN A
SITUATION HITTING THE TARGET NOT
HITTING BYSTANDERS IS DIFFICULT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND EXPECT
THAT THE AVERAGE CITIZEN WOULD
PERFORM. BETTER.
IT'S DOUBTFUL I BELIEVE.
THEIR IT OUT IN REFERENCE TO US
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
SUPPORTERS THERE IS A LIST OF
CRIMES THE MISDEEDS COMMITTED BY
CCW HOLDERS. ON THE VIOLENCE
POLICY CENTER WEBSITE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO LOOK AT THAT LIST.
.
THERE HAVE BEEN STUDIES THAT.
MORE PEOPLE CARRYING GUNS HAS
NOT.
IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY FOR THOSE
PEOPLE OR THOSE STATES AND IN
FACT A NEW STUDY CAME OUT LAST
YEAR.
BY THE STE BY I WAS A STANFORD
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL STUDY. THAT
FOUND THAT STATES THAT ADOPTED
RIGHT TO CARRY LAWS WHICH
BASICALLY R. SHALL ISSUE STATES
HAVE EXPERIENCE A THIRTEEN TO
FIFTEEN PERCENT INCREASE IN
VIOLENT CRIME. IN THE TEN YEARS
AFTER ENACTING THOSE LOS
FEELING SAFER WITH A GUN
DOESN'T MEAN ONE. IS SAFER AND
IN FACT OFTEN NOT ALWAYS BUT
OFTEN BEHAVIOR CHANGES WHEN ONE
CARRIES A GUN. AND THAT PERSON
AND OTHERS MAY BE A GREATER
RISK.
I WOULD REMIND YOU OF THE
SHOOTING OF TRAYVON MARTIN IN
FLORIDA.
I BELIEVE THAT GEORGE
ZIMMERMAN'S BEHAVIOR MAY HAVE
BEEN DIFFERENT HE MAY NOT HAVE
FOLLOW TRAYVON AND SHOT HIM IF
HE HAD NOT BEEN CARRYING A GUN.
IKE KNOWLEDGE THAT AT TIMES
WARILY.
DEATH SELF DEFENSE SITUATION
DOES HAPPEN BY SOMEONE WHO WAS
ARMED.
BUT I THINK.
THE BREASTS.
OF HAVING MORE LOADED HITTING
GUNS IN PUBLIC FAR OUTWEIGH ANY
BENEFIT OR PERCEIVED BENEFIT
SITE URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HAVE A QUESTION BLACKIE.
YEAH I WOULD I WOULD COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH THE FACT THAT.
THE GOOD BECAUSE PROVISIONS
BEEN ABUSED.
AND.
AS IT IS UNFAIR CONSIDERATION
HOWEVER I I DO NEED SOME SOME
CLARIFICATION ON.
THE PORTION OF THE BILL THAT
TALKS ABOUT.
AND THEN AND IT STATES THAT
NOTWITHSTANDING ANY PROVISION OF
LAW PERSON WHO POSSESSES A
VALID.
A LICENSE TO CARRY CONCEALED
FIREARM IS EXEMPT FROM
PERSECUTION UNDER ANY STATE LAW
REGULATION THAT PROHIBITS.
THE POSSESSION OF A FIREARM OR
AMMUNITION WITHIN A CERTAIN
SPECIFIED LOCATION.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO.
PENAL CODE ONE SEVENTY ONE FOR
EXAMPLE CRIME TO BRING FIREMAN
TO CAPITAL.
OR FIREARMS.
THE SHOW SO FORTH AND SO ON.
SO THOSE EXEMPTIONS.
THAT KINDA GOES BEYOND THE.
GOOD BECAUSE PEACE.
COULDN'T COULD SOMEONE EXPLAIN
THAT TO ME.
SURE.
.
SIMILAC A THESE PLACES WHERE.
THAT THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS ARE
PLACES WHERE NEVER. ON GUNS
AVAILABLE ESPECIALLY GUN SHOWS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT THEY ARE
SAFE PLACES THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
ALSO ABIDE BY THE LAW ACCORDING
TO THE LEGISLATURE WHO HAS DONE.
SIGNIFICANT RESEARCH AND FOUND
THAT THAT GUN SHOWS ARE SOME OF
THE SAFEST PLACES IN THE WORLD.
IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT PEOPLE
ARE NOT VIOLATING THE LAW AND.
THERE WOULD BE NO ADDITIONAL
DANGER BY ALLOWING PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
IN OTHER IN ALL PLACES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE PROVISIONS THAT SAY
YOU CAN'T BRING IT ON THE
CAPITAL.
THERE ARE NOW STATES WHO HAVE
OVERTURNED THAT ARE ALLOWING
CITIZENS TO TO TO CARRY
CONCEALED LEGALLY ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS IN HEARINGS AND. NOTHING
HAS HAPPENED.
.
YOU KNOW IF.
IF THAT PROVISION OF THE BILL IT
EVEN IF IT WERE TO BE STRUCK AND
AND AND SHALL ISSUE WOULD BE
SUPPORTED. I THINK YOU'D
PROBABLY FIND SOME SUPPORT BUT
THE LOGIC IS THAT.
IF YOU ARE SAYING THE PEOPLE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
OUTSIDE OF THEIR HOME.
THAT WAS INDICATED BY JUSTICE
SCALIA AND IN IN HELLER.
CONVERSES WASHINGTON DC.
ADMITTING THAT THIS HAD TO COME
BACK TO THE SUPREME COURT FOR
ADDITIONAL.
EXPLORATION AS TO HOW FAR THAT
MEANT.
THEN THAT THAT KINDA TELLS YOU
THAT PEOPLE REALLY SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
ANYWHERE THEY GO.
PERIOD.
AND AND IT ALSO CLARIFY. EXACTLY
ZERO VIOLENT GUN CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
BY CZW HOLDERS THESE ARE THE
SAFEST PEOPLE WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS CONCEPT WAS
JUST BROUGHT UP.
BY THE OTHER WITNESS THE
TESTIFIED THAT THESE PEOPLE WERE
UNVEILED IN THIS TAKES AWAY TOOL
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS ABSOLUTELY
INCORRECT.
TO GET A CCW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GUARD SO JURISDICTION
OR GETTING IN YOU HAVE TO
THROUGH EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND
CHECK. AND PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
KNOWN CRIMINAL HISTORY OR ARE AT
RISK YOU NOT PEOPLE GETTING SEE
CW'S THIS IS WHY IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN I WOULD REITERATE
THERE WAS ZERO. INCIDENCES OF
VIOLENT CRIME VIOLENT GUN CRIME
COMMITTEE LIKE ANY CCW HOLDERS
IN ANY OF THE THIRTY NINE
MILLION RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE YOU
ACTUALLY WANT TO BE HAVING A
FIREARM. IF THERE'S AN INCIDENT.
POLICE ARE TYPICALLY MINUTES IF
NOT LONGER AWAY TO HAVE A CCW
HOLDER IN THE CROWD THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AND TO PROTECT OTHERS THAT ARE
AT RISK. COULD OF SAVED NUMEROUS
LIVES IN COUNTLESS CERTAIN.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
YEAH ALL.
THIS IS JUST A COMMENT.
I HAVE LOOKED AT THE DATA.
SEALED CARRY PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA MAY WELL BE. ARE NOT
COMMITTING.
VIOLENT CRIMES OUTSIDE THE
STATE THEY ARE AND I THINK THAT
JUST SAYS THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
LAW NOW.
FOOD IS SO IF YOU PLEASE CLARIFY
THAT WHO DESERVES A COMET OKAY
YONI DANCER.
ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. INCOME.
YOU MAY CLOSE MR ALLEN.
YOU'RE A MUCH.
CONCEALED CARRY LAWS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE DISCRIMINATORY.
DEPENDING UPON WHERE YOU LIVE
LOCAL SHERIFFS ARE STOPPING YOUR
RIGHTS TO PROTECT YOURSELF
FOR INSTANCE IF YOU LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. WERE OVER TEN
MILLION OTHER CALIFORNIANS LIVE
WITH YOU ONLY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE PEOPLE IN YOUR
COUNTY.
GIVING ISSUED A CCW PERMIT DOES
THIS MEAN THAT THE REST OF THE
TEN MILLION PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE SAME RIGHT TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. ONCE THEY LEAVE
THEIR HOME. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN ZERO CRIMES ZERO
VIOLENT GUN CRIMES WERE
COMMITTED BY ANY CCW HOLDER
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE.
NATIONWIDE OVER THREE MILLION
INCIDENCES OF VIOLENT CRIME WERE
PREVENTED.
BY PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO CARRY
A WEAPON.
CONTRAST THAT WITH ONLY SIXTEEN
THOUSAND INCIDENCES OF GUN
VIOLENCE OR OF OF GUN DEATHS IN
THE NATION.
THREE MILLION INCIDENCES OF
VIOLENT CRIME WERE PREVENTED IN
CALIFORNIA. THE NUMBER WOULD BE
ROUGHLY ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THAT NUMBER. SO WE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL RISK OF ALLOWING SOMEONE
WHO'S GONE THROUGH EXTENSIVE
BACKGROUND CHECKS HAS BEEN
VETTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
HAS NO PRIOR CRIMINAL RECORD. OF
RECEIVING A CCW AND HAVING THE
ABILITY TO CARRY THAT ANYWHERE
IN THE STATE. THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRULY THE FIRST
RESPONDERS THESE ARE YOU THESE
ARMY THIS IS YOUR WIFE YOUR
DAUGHTER YOUR NEIGHBOR YOUR
FRIEND.
A FRIENDLY PERSON IN THE CROWD
THAT HAS THE ABILITY TO NOT ONLY
PROTECT THEMSELVES BUT TO
PROTECT YOU WHEN POLICE ARE
MINUTES OR LONGER AWAY.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
IS A RIGHT
TO PERSONAL PROTECTION.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT GIVES ALL
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND ALL
UNITED STATES CITIZENS THE RIGHT
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES TO PROTECT
THEIR FAMILIES NOT JUST IN YOUR
HOME BUT WHEN YOU WALK DOWN THE
STREET. IMAGINE YOUR WIFE IS
GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE SHE'S
IN THE PARKING LOT SHE CALLS YOU
SHE'S NERVOUS THERE SOME PEOPLE
IN THE PARKING LOT THAT ARE
THREATENING HER.
WOULDN'T YOU FEEL BETTER IF SHE
HAD THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
HERSELF.
IN MANYCOUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
SHE DOES SHE CAN GET THE CCW
ISSUED BUT IN MANY OTHER
COUNTIES SHE CANNOT.
IN LOS ANGELES AND SAN FRANCISCO
THE RESIDENTS OF THE RESIDENCES
THE RED I'M SO IN LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO THE RESIDENTS
OF THESE COUNTIES ARE LEFT
UNPROTECTED. THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO OBTAIN CCW
PERMITS.
BECAUSE THERE LOCAL SHERIFF'S.
ONE ISSUE THESE.
THE CONCEPT OF GOOD CAUSE AS
BEEN OVER USED AND ABUSED BY
LIBERAL.
OR IDEOLOGICAL SHARES.
THEY HAVE A PREDISPOSITION TO
NOT ALLOWING THEIR LAW BITING
CITIZENS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES.
THIS IS WRONG THIS IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THIS SHOULD BE
CORRECTED. THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THAT THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE CALIFORNIA A SHALL ISSUE
CCW STATE IT'S ABOUT TIME WE
GIVE CALIFORNIANS THE RIGHT TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES. THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
THANK YOU MR ON.
.
ACTUALLY IT YOU MADE SOME GOOD
POINTS IN AND.
AND IN EUROPE THE PROPONENTS OF
YOUR THAT MADE SOME GOOD POINTS
EVEN MISTER DILUTES WHO WHO
EDUCATED US. WHAT HAPPENED IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR BUT I WOULD?
ALSO HAVE YOU COME TO MY OFFICE
I HAVE A PICTURE OF THE BLACK
PANTHERS.
BROUGHT GUNS INTO HIS BUILDING
AND IMMEDIATELY AFTER. THAT WAS
OUTLAWED SO I UNDERSTAND WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT DISCRIMINATORY.
TOWARD PEOPLE AYE. AYE I GET
THAT.
BUT THE MOST COMPELLING THING.
THAT THAT YOU SAID AND IF YOU'VE
REPEATED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN IS THAT CCW HOLDERS AND
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA RACKET ZERO.
PROBLEMS
WHICH SAYS TO ME EXISTING LAWS
THAT WE HAVE MUST BE PRETTY GOOD
IF YOU HAVE A ZERO CC W.
HOLDERS.
COMMITTING CRIMES FOR DOING SOME
EVEN THE MOST HORRENDOUS STINKS
THAT WEEKS WE'VE SEEN NOW.
AND I WOULD RATHER HAVE.
SOME YOU KNOW DEPUTY CHIEF.
LACKEY AND HELMET DECIDING
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEBODY IN THAT
LOCAL COMMUNITY. GETS A CCW
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT PERSON.
I DON'T.
OUT OF LOS ANGELES AND SO HAVING
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON MONICA THAT I
THINK IS REALLY REALLY REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT. I
ALSO THINK IT'S.
IT'S THE REASON WHY WE HAD SUCH
A SUCCESS WITH CCW HOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T THINK THIS BILL.
HELP US WITH THAT AND THE FACT
THAT THE MAY EXACERBATE THE
PROBLEM. AND SO I WOULD HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR A NO VOTE MAKE COLORADO.
LEFT.
I KNEW IT WAS COMING BUT NO IT.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
NAY JONES SAWYER NAY LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE KOREA.
CORREO NAY GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NO KILEY.
KILEY NOT BOATING QUIRK.
NO QUIRK NOW SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO.
I'M SORRY THAT MEASURE FAILS
THEY CAN THANK YOU FOR FOR
BRINGING IT TO THE COMMITTEE.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR GUNS
ALICE.
FLETCHER.
CRIMINAL LAW DNA COLLECTION.
MINERS.
SECOND.
I THINK YEAH.
IT'S CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE MAKE
SURE OUR KIDS AREN'T STOP LIKE
HAPPEN IN MY DISTRICT AND I ASK
FOR THE POLICE FOR DNA SWAB TO
BE KEPT IN A LOCAL DATABASE.
RESPECT LAST YEAR ABOUT.
ANY OTHER BEEN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
CLEARLY. ORGAN. I'M REALLY GOING
TO BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL ONE
TO CLARIFY WHETHER OR NOT
BIOLOGICAL SAMPLES INCLUDE BLOOD
OR BREATH TESTING FOR DO YOU AYE
CASES.
IT DOES INCLUDE BLOOD.
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE BRED A
BREATHALYZER IS NOT I DON'T
BELIEVE IN ANY.
.
HE SLOB A BIOLOGICAL SAMPLE AM I
WILL CLARIFY THAT PETA IT DOES
INCLUDE BLOOD IT THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
YESTERDAY.
.
AND SOMETHING WE MAY CONSIDER.
WORKING ON THE OTHER THING IN
ALL HONESTY BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS IS
IF WE HAVE.
LAWS ABOUT THE USE OF MARIJUANA
OR DRUG TESTING AND DRIVING IN
WE MAY HAVE TO MAKE.
.
SOME EXCLUSIONS ON AYE
COLLECTING BUT NOT STORY IN.
THAT
TYPE UP WHAT.
OKAY I I MEAN I AM NOT TRYING TO
PRECLUDE IT IT'S A STRANGE
SITUATION RIGHT BECAUSE IT COULD
BE EXCULPATORY UNSETTLE YOU
WOULD WANT.
SOMEBODY WHO SAYS YOU KNOW. A
KID.
THINKING THROUGH FACT PATTERN
WHO.
IS DRIVING ERRATICALLY GETS
PULLED OVER DOESN'T BLOW UMPIRE
FOR WHATEVER REASON OUR DOESN'T
PASS THE TEST BUT DOESN'T BLOW
IT AND THEY WANT TO DO BLOOD IN
THAT.
MAYBE THEIR MEDS ARE OFTEN SO
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO AND THAT'S BECAUSE
SITUATION IT'S GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARIFICATION
I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOUR
OFFICE BECAUSE I I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE. YOU'RE FORWARD THINKING
ON THIS TOO ADAM ESPECIALLY WITH
DRIVING SO BE HAPPY OR FREE
OFFICE AND HOW WE DO THAT WAS SO
MAINTAINING THAT THE PRIVACY OF
THE MINOR THE FROM THE CORNER
WORKING WITH HIM. THINK.
ARE YOU ARE SMALL I THINK I'M
OKAY WITH THIS TOO.
DE YOU MENTION THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT IN THE ANALYSIS OF
THIS ORDER PART OF YOU OFFER
STATEMENT I THINK IS IT IS IT
YOUR VIEW THAT THIS IS.
FOURTH AMENDMENT ISSUE IS KIND
OF GOING I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
POLICY.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT WAS IN THE
AUTHOR STATEMENT I COULD BE
WRONG IT MIGHT BE AN ANALYSIS.
MAYBE THAT HOUSE IMMIGRANT
MAYBE.
LOOK AT IT REGARDLESS OF THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT.
IT'S HIGHLY OFFENSIVE FOR ME AS
A MOTHER OF A TEENAGER.
TO TO THINK ABOUT HIM WALKING
DOWN THE STREET LITERALLY BEEN
STOPPED BY POLICE OFFICER THIS
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT IT. AT
THE POOL THAT MY SON GOES TO
EVERYDAY.
KID FOR WEARING BLUE WAS STOPPED
ANNOUNCED FOR DNA SAMPLE IN A
KID.
IS JUST SIGNED AWAY THEIR
CONSENT BECAUSE
I MEAN MY MY SON'S FATHER CHP
OFFICER POLICE TOLD HIM HEY
SIGNED THIS AND GIVE US A A SWAB
YOUR TO HE WOULD DO IT.
IT'S WRONG AND AND WE HAVE TO
START TO PROTECT.
OUR YOUNG FOLKS PRIVACY AS MUCH
AS WE CARE ABOUT.
AROUND AND SO.
YEAH IT'S KIND OF AYE
INTERESTING ISSUE BECAUSE WE
HAVE THIS YOU KNOW QUESTION OF
PARENTAL CONSENT AND DIFFERENT
CONTACTS. WE'RE DEALING WITH
MINORS.
INCLUDING WITHIN CRIMINAL
CONTACTS DAD YOU NEED PRODUCTION
SENT.
TO BEGIN QUESTIONING I DON'T
BELIEVE SO SO I JUST KIND OF
WONDERING WHAT. IN YOUR VIEW IS
KIND OF THE STANDARD FOR WHAT WE
SEPARATE THINGS THAT REQUIRE
PARENTAL CONSENT FROM. THOSE
THAT DOWN AND WHY DOES THIS FALL
ON ONE PARTICULAR SIDELINED.
MY AYE I ANTICIPATED.
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE THIS
QUESTION I THINK YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE HEALTH
DECISIONS PEOPLE MAKE WITHOUT
PARENTAL CONSENT I'M NOT OKAY
WAS BROUGHT UP BY OUR STAFF SO.
TO BE CLEAR.
.
I I THINK THAT IN AREAS WHERE
THERE IS AN ABILITY TO I'M HAVE
SELF DETERMINATION BY YOUNG
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE HEALTH
DECISIONS THAT'S ONE THING.
WHERE THEY'RE BEING COERCED
AND AND THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN
TELL ME THAT YOUNG PERSON IS NOT
BEING COERCED WHEN A POLICE
OFFICER STOPS A MOUSE THEM TO?
CONSENT TO SOMETHING THAT
THAT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SITUATION IT WAS THE SAME
SITUATION WITH I THINK LAST YEAR
WE DID THE MIRANDA RIGHTS ISSUE.
EIGHT THAT THE THE.
AUTHORITY FIGURE.
COMING AND ASKING THEM TO
CONSENTED SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
TOLD HOPEFULLY MOST OF US HAVE.
NOW MY NEIGHBORHOODS A LITTLE
BIT MORE BEGRUDGINGLY BUT TOLD
PEOPLE TO.
TO TRUST THE POLICE AND AND TO
DO WHAT THEY SAY.
I THINK WE HAVEN'T PROVIDED OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
CONSENT FULL DISCLOSURE.
IN MEDICAL SITUATIONS I THINK.
IN PARTICULAR WITH.
.
YOUNG PERSONS RIGHT TO MAKE
MEDICAL DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
IT'S A AT COMPLEX COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SITUATION WHERE
THEY'RE SEEKING OUT.
.
SOMETHING BE DONE NOT BEEN
COERCED TO DO IT.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT MEDICAL
DECISION THAT MEAN THAT THAT'S
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD ANSWER I
THINK THIS IDEA OF COERCION I'M.
OF COURSE IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SORT OF.
IN HOPE OF BEING OPEN TO
QUESTIONS BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND DOESN'T REQUIRE CONSENT THAT
SAME ARGUMENT FIVE SO I THINK
THAT THAT. IS WHY DO I TELL NOT
TO ANSWER.
RIGHT AS I YOU CAN TEACH YOUR
CHILD NOT CONSENT TO.
AND GIVE EXAMPLES BUT I.
SO I I WAS THE BILL I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW YOU'RE.
YOUR INTUITIONS R. REPLY RIGHT I
JUST THINK WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
FULLY FORMED KIND OF THEORY. AS
TO WIN.
YOU KNOW CONSENT.
SHOULD BE THERE WHEN IT SHOULD.
SUCH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENT YOU
MAY CLOSE.
RESPECT LAST BUT I'VE UP. CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING THAT AND I VOTE AND
AYE I'LL JUST ADD. ON.
AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN MALE. WE
A MINORITY DEALING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOW YOU ANSWER.
COULD HAVE SOME DEVASTATING.
IMPACTS ON THE SITE I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING HIS FORK IS
IMPORTANT.
AB FIFTY STANIFORTH THE MOTION
IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY OKAY CORREO.
KOREA AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
THANK YOU. BOB ON A BE A SEVEN
FIVE COOPER PETTY THEFT. THERE
WAS NO SECOND.
THERE IS NO SECOND.
SO.
THE GUYS WILL GO ONTO THE NEXT
ONE. IS HEALTH.
SO THAT'S THE END OF OUR.
DO ALL ADD ONS NOW.
NOT ALL CALLS.
ON AB ONE.
I'M SORRY ITEM NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY TWO GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
THAT'S ME.
I KINDLY. THAT'S ME.
KILEY NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY ITEM NUMBER
THREE.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T KNOW BEFORE WITH HELPING
COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWELVE SIXTY
TWO GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO.
NOT A PROBLEM.
AND ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHT
TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY MISTER
GARCIA.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER SIX HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN WAS ON
CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HAVE BEEN
DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL. CORREO.
THREE AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THANK YOU OFTHAT COMMITTEE
MEETING IS NOW ADJOURNED